[Music]
Career and Technical Education or CTE
may be the most popular notion in school
reform today but for CTE to be more than
another fad schools need to make some
difficult choices about exactly how it
will work my friend and former state
superintendent Tony Bennett recently
flagged three key questions about CTE
that need to be resolved one
well we accept that expanding CTE may
eliminate some traditional teaching
positions many CTE students spend part
of the school day learning workforce
skills which means schools may not need
as many teachers - well we accept the
traditional teacher preparation is
inadequate for CTE instructors schools
of Education don't prepare graduates to
teach skill based occupations such as
welding or firefighting 3 well we accept
CPEs reliance on high-stakes testing
many CTE students must pass a national
state or industry based assessment to be
certified in their chosen field for CTE
to deliver on its promise schools have
to confront some tough decisions what do
you think of Career and Technical
Education let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI